- It's a very special time.
- Yeah.
- Invest.
You can buy stuff later.
- Yeah, that's what I'm doing.
(electronic music)
- You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat hip-hop music)
- What's really driven me
as a trader is freedom.
- Yes.
- My goal, which yes
I've completed for now,
but as I stretch my life,
is I just wanted to be an artist,
just have that as a job role,
not have a boss, et cetera, which I have,
least I can make it stretch.
All that's filler is
sometimes, my work ethic
is not as crazy is when
I have to do a whole
other job 40 hours a week.
It's just like, it's become my whole life.
- Look I think, listen,
here's what I would say.
Don't judge yourself either.
How old are you?
- 25.
- You know, take into account
that you're 25, right?
Like do you have a relationship?
- Yeah, five years.
- Right so like, you know you got
that's a part of your life.
You're 25 like, it's okay to like,
I'm sure you have other interests
whether it's to watch a
film or to eat a little food
or a proper football team
like, I don't judge myself.
During my whole career when I wanted to
maximize every minute, it
didn't even cross my mind
that on Sundays, 16 times a year,
I did nothing but watch the Jets.
Like, I think the thing
that people do poorly
is they judge themselves.
Okay, so what you're
telling is at 25, you feel
that your work ethic is a little softer
than when you were forced to but who says
that your work ethic
won't be greater at 32?
- Yeah, yeah.
- When you see that
three dimensional art in
on the moon is a new white space 'cause
Elon got us on the moon.
- That's like always changing so well.
- I think too many
people judge themselves.
I used to think I worked
harder than everyone
when I worked from 7 A.M. to
11 P.M. in the liquor store.
But in those hours in that liquor store,
and it was more 8 A.M. let me not even
paint the wrong picture.
8 A.M. to 10 P.M., let's
actually be more fair.
In those you know 14 hours,
I had down time compared to today
'cause technology wasn't the same way.
I didn't have an iPhone.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like, you know like
if four people called out
and I had to be on the actual floor
not on the computer selling wine,
if nobody walked in I was kind of stuck.
Maybe I could like make some
signs but if I had my phone,
I could've been on
Instagram and sold wine.
So where I'm going is okay, good.
Enjoy the rest because--
- But I don't wanna ever be resting.
Not like that, I do rest.
- But you understand?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, I get you, I get you.
- Look, listen, there's another thing
that people don't talk about, talent.
- Yeah.
- Athletes.
- Some people are just
born unbelievably talented
and they don't have to work as hard
and they never do because they were,
they can run like a gazelle, right?
- Exactly.
- You know, probably one
of the things that you're
quantifying and dealing with is, you know,
you have talent and so the talent is
maybe allowing you a little freedom
in the work ethic department currently.
(hip-hop drum beat)
- My name's Mark, I wanna thank you
because you had a massive,
massive impact on me.
(banging sound)
- So I have a studio animation company.
- Yes.
(hip-hop music)
(upbeat pop music)
- Gary?
- That's me.
- Up the stairs and go.
- It's funny.
I don't know what to do with this one
so here's my theory.
Politics advertising, shitting
on your competitor wins.
That's exactly what
brands should be doing.
Pepsi's only moment was the
Pepsi Challenge Coke sucks.
Wendy's is effectively
hurting McDonald's right now
shitting on them.
Every brand if it's not number one,
should shit on number one
as their entire strategy and it will work.